Donald Trump's defense team has a novel
argument for his acquittal that the
president asking Ukraine for dirt on a
political opponent maybe in his personal
interest and also in the interest of the
United States making him immune if a
president does something which he
believes will help him get elected in
the public interest that cannot be the
kind of quid pro quo that results in
impeachment Democrats prosecuting Trump
say his intent was purely for political
gain
so all quid pros are not the same some
are legitimate and some are corrupt and
you don't need to be a mind reader to
figure out which is which for one thing
you can ask John Bolton John Bolton
Trump's former national security adviser
reportedly claims in an upcoming book
that Trump directly tied his hold on
security aid to Ukraine to his demand
for investigations into Joe Biden in a
letter obtained by Al Jazeera the White
House warns Bolton not to publish his
book without deleting classified
information on Twitter Wednesday Trump
said the book was nasty untrue and all
classified Democrats want to call Bolton
as a witness
they'll need support from four
Republican senators to make that happen
they vote no they're saying this is a
sham
they're saying we don't want to hear the
truth what does that say to America
about this body meanwhile someone else
was all but begging for senators to call
him to testify
humph donor left part Asst says he was
dispatched to Ukraine by Trump's
attorney to stir up dirt useful for
Trump's re-election Parnas is under
federal indictment for campaign fraud
and says he came to the capital wearing
an ankle monitor to make amends
Democrats have acknowledged getting
Republicans to agree to witnesses is an
uphill battle that question will be put
to a vote Friday if the answer is no
Trump could be immediately acquitted hi
Joe Castro al Jazeera Washington